rise and shine it's an espresso time
good morning relief nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in that amazing gift you have
inside to you that needs to be shared
with the world so let's start the day
off right together grab your cup of
coffee and sit on today's message enrich
the lives of others over to you Steve
Jobs there's a lot of forces in life
that tend to tend to funnel us down into
this institutionalized path and where
people you know and where people
sometimes forget that that they're very
unique and that they have very unique
feelings and perspectives and again it's
you know the whole computer industry
wants to forget about the humanist side
and just focus on the technology and a
lot of our industry focuses just on more
is better more megahertz and megabytes
and you know speeds and feeds we call it
but we think there's a whole other side
to the coin which is what do you do with
these things can we do more than just
spreadsheets and word processors can we
help you express yourself in richer ways
in your music in your movies in your
photography and these kinds of things
that people want to do I love this
message and this is essentially what's
at the core of core selling what I talk
about my book your one word it's not
just about selling the features it's not
about selling the benefits that works
but it's inefficient the best companies
in the world the ones where you feel an
affinity towards that you love or some
reason it's because you are attached to
their core message so Steve Jobs in this
video isn't talking about how fast his
computer is he's not even talking about
how more
you can get your job done that's
features and that's benefits features is
our computers go this fast benefits are
it'll help you get your job done three
times faster right what he's talking
about is something totally different
it's something totally on a higher level
way more powerful that if you guys learn
to bring us into your business it's when
your sales start to explode he's talking
about helping people express themselves
he's saying we believe in you you are a
creator you're gonna go off and make
something amazing in the world we want
to help you express that and that's what
we stand for is the business and that's
what our products help you do so now
when you buy a map when you're looking
at Apple products you're not just
thinking is this gonna be the fastest
thing it's just gonna help me do my job
faster no you think I'm a hero I'm gonna
express myself I'm gonna create art I'm
gonna change the world I'm gonna have a
big impact that's what you feel at least
that's the intent right that's what
Steve Jobs is trying to portray that's
what he believes it's the intent is that
when you pick up a Mac and you open it
up and you start doing work you're doing
something important to change the world
you're doing something important to
express yourself and get that thing
inside out of you into the world that's
core selling that's what it's all about
and when you can start to build that
into your business when it's not just
about the products and service that you
create but what you staying for as first
human being and then you bring to your
company that's when you get loyal fans
that's when you get people buying from
you without even looking at what the
product or service does oh you're cute
up with the new product I'm instantly
interested there are some of you who are
watching these videos who are loyal
subscribers who will watch any video
that I put out because it's coming for
me because I've built up that trust
because I'm about believing because you
want to believe more and there's the
auto like the auto subscribe you oughta
watch that next video now if I start
doing a bad job if I start putting out
anti belief content I start putting out
hate against somebody maybe you start to
question that but I've become a filter
for a lot of you to say this is going to
be a good video is gonna help me in my
life and in my business and when I come
up with a product a book a second book
then it's something that you're
interested in where it's not about how
many pay
or in that block it's not about oh
there's a cup the book cost ten dollars
or fifteen or twenty like what's the
exact benefit that I'm gonna get out of
this book but those aren't the questions
you're asking like evans print out this
book top ten I love top ten I'm gonna
buy that book now that's not all of you
I get that there's a certain segment but
that's what I want for your business I
want the things you create to have a
powerful emotion across all the people
who are consuming your stuff consuming
your content reading your blog follow me
on social media buying your products and
services visiting your website I want
them to feel something what are they
feeling when they're working with your
business you can transfer that emotion
to an impact in their life that by
looking at your product or service and
makes them feel a certain way a good way
about themselves
you can change with that emotion onto
them then by using the Mac it makes them
feel like they're expressing themselves
that by just looking at the book and
makes you feel more successful when you
get to that place that's where you win
that's where you have a huge impact
that's where it's not just about the
price anymore and I want that so badly
for you I explain that concept of course
selling in my book you're one word I
hope you check it out but if not just
listen to Steve Jobs again play this
message back and start to apply that
concept to your business so the question
today today is I'm curious what is the
emotion that you're trying to transfer
to your clients what do you want people
to feel when they consume something of
yours what is that feeling that you're
trying to transfer over let me know
leaving the comments below
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick charter to Terry Whelan
from Terry Williams blog spot.com Terry
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word and posting
that picture online
I really really appreciate the support
man and I hope you enjoyed the read so
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you and I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events Bessette
this prey so give me go
so one of the ideas that we had a few
years ago was that we would be better
off with more and more people in our
ecosystem and the best way to do that is
to essentially help entrepreneurs be
successful that doesn't mean they're
captive to us they're still gonna use
competitor products and competitor ad
systems and competitor platforms but it
seems one of the things that people
don't understand when they view business
is they assume that business is I'll
describe it it's a zero-sum game but if
company a wins company B loses I'll tell
you that when Yahoo was young and Terry
Semel was running it whenever he and his
company would win a deal I would call
him to congratulate him and whenever we
would win a deal he would call me to
congratulate me now by the way we were
tough competitors why would we do that
because we both understood that we were
building a larger market so you can
understand our our goal as philanthropic
you can understand it as making the
world a better place but you can also
understand it as self-interested in the
building more people who understand the
concepts of network computing and
platforms and so forth benefits everyone
including Google if you had to think of
one word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details